today mike pompeo did what none of his
predecessors dared or
even wanted to do he stepped foot onto
an israeli
settlement land the international
community considers illegally occupied
land palestinians say belongs to them
like pompeo's boss president trump
today's visit was provocative and in
your face moment for palestinians
donald trump began his presidency by
swearing allegiance to america's
pro-israel policy
more precisely the policy of israeli
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
palestinians have never been included in
any trump negotiations or decisions
regarding
the middle east but donald trump leaves
office in january
and that leaves little time for more
than last minute legacy
building if that was indeed the purpose
of pompeo's visit
could today's embrace of israel be part
of donald trump's planned
2024 political resurrection
or could today have been a casting call
for a future u.s presidential candidate
named mike pompeo
it's a first for israeli-american
relations and a parting gift from
america's outgoing top diplomat
mike pompeo's visit to the golan heights
makes him the first u.s secretary of
state to visit the disputed territory
since israel seized the region in 1967
the united nations may have rejected the
annexation
but for pompeo and the trump
administration
this is israeli land
you can't stand here and stare out at
what's across the border
and deny the central thing that
president trump recognized that previous
presidents had refused to do
that this is a part of israel the
central part of israel
in another unprecedented move pompeo
made a stop to an israeli settlement in
the west bank
angering some palestinians who say it
legitimizes what they view as illegal
israeli settlements
the secretary of state had no scheduled
meetings with palestinian leaders
some have called the trip a victory lap
of sorts a chance for the trump
administration to highlight what it sees
as its diplomatic success in the region
including taking steps to legitimize
israeli settlements for a long time the
state department
took the wrong view of settlements uh it
took a view
that didn't recognize the history of
this special place
and instead now today the united states
department of state stands strongly to
the recognition that
settlements can be done in a way that
are lawful and appropriate
and proper a stance that puts the u.s at
odds with many international bodies
and that could prove to be a stumbling
block for incoming president-elect
joe biden
and for more i'm joined tonight by a
respected voice
in the geopolitics of the middle east
trinida parsi is an award-winning author
who has written several books on u.s
foreign policy in the region he's also
executive vice president of the quincy
institute for responsible
statecraft trinity it's good to have you
back on
the day let's look at what mr pompeo did
today a visit to the occupied golan
heights and then a visit to an israeli
settlement in the occupied west bank
what was pompeo trying to do today
well we can only speculate and i think
your reporting has already
suggested that this could very much be a
part of a
desire by pompeo to boost his own bid
for
2024 and maybe to be able to boost
trump's
second bid all of those things are
valid speculations in my view what we
should not be forgetting though is that
regardless of their intent this is going
to have real and frankly devastating
consequences for uh the region as well
as for u.s security because
these are measures that is locking in
the united states
in a posture in the middle east that
makes it increasingly
stuck and increasingly complicit
in the illegal activities of some of its
allies and this is ultimately bad for
the region and ultimately about for the
united states as well
regardless of the intent or the
political motivation of pompeo
i want you to take a listen to what the
secretary of state said
today about iran indeed the commitment
we've made the ironclad commitment we've
made to the jewish state
will continue uh it was i'm confident
that after our conversation this morning
we talked about how we can protect
americans and israelis in the region
from the regime in tehran you talked
about this
they remain we should not take for
granted
they remain the foremost state sponsor
of terrorism in all the world
and israel has provided outstanding
support to our pressure campaign
which we have no intention of relaxing
so trudeau how does pompeo's message
square
with president-elect joe biden's
intention to try to revive the iran
nuclear deal
well pompeo is doing absolutely
everything he can to make sure
that biden's options are as limited as
possible
and that it does not lead to him being
able to
return to the jcpoa or in any other
measure
and i think this is really critical uh
this is also what he is trying to do
when it comes to moving the embassy to
jerusalem
recognizing these settlements making
these visits because they're
counting on the idea that biden simply
does not have enough political courage
to reverse some of these policies
policies that he himself deemed to be
devastating for u.s national security
but that he doesn't have
what it takes to make sure that there's
a pushback against it
unfortunately that calculation may be
proved true because when we take a look
at what's been happening on the u.s
israeli front and the treatment of
settlements there has been a gradual
acceptance of illegal sediments at
something that the u.s at first
objected to later on viewed as an
obstacle to peace later on became more
neutral towards to what we have right
now a complete embrace
of illegal settlements and violation of
international law
and i think in some ways the pompeo and
trump administration may have gone too
far they may have
pushed it so far that biden may have no
choice to but really
push back even though he will likely pay
a political price for doing so
what do you think it's possible that joe
biden could
stay the course when it comes to
accepting
israeli settlements but really trying to
do a 180
with the policy on the iran nuclear deal
and tried to revive that deal could i
mean could he have both of these things
happening at the same time
he could and that's likely what's going
to happen because the political costs of
reversing
uh the policies on israel are going to
be higher than trying to go back into
the nuclear deal i mean
we should not forget the uh democratic
platform explicitly says that a
democratic president should be going
back into the nuclear deal
and beyond that also negotiate further
uh having additional negotiations with
iran there is no such language in terms
of settlements for instance so
i think the political price will be
lower on the iranian front
but i think what's really important to
keep in mind here is
that democratic presidents all too often
have
ended up accepting the limitations and
the framework that
previous republican presidents have
imposed on them we saw that as well when
it came to
how the obama administration dealt with
a lot of the legacies of the
bush administration and and the question
is is there enough political will to
really actually have president biden
define his framework himself
and define whatever limitations he has
himself instead of letting him
be defined by president trump or
secretary pompeo
yeah apropos definition in defining
pompeo
attempted to expand the definition of
anti-semitism
today take a listen to what he said
today i want to
make one announcement with respect to
a decision by the state department that
we will regard the global anti-israel
bds campaign as anti-semitic
i know this sounds simple to you mr
prime minister seems
it seems like a statement of fact but i
want you to know that we will
immediately take steps to identify
organizations that engage
in hateful bds conduct and withdraw us
government support
now judy he's also talking about people
who
want to boycott israel
not necessarily because they're
anti-semites but he's saying he wants to
consider them as
anti-semites is that going to have any
legal leg to stand on in the united
states
it's likely going to be challenged by
aclu and a lot of other organizations
because this is a freedom of speech
issue
i mean on the one hand uh pompeo is
imposing crippling sanctions on iran
that have been devastating for ordinary
people limited their access to medicine
in the midst of a pandemic
and on the other hand he's trying to say
that even if individuals on their own
voluntary bases decide that they don't
want to buy
oranges from israel then that suddenly
turns them into anti-semites so there's
going to be massive legal uh challenges
to this i'm confident
but what i think more than anything this
shows is that you are now
an administration that is just agreeing
to whatever
bibi netanyahu is telling them that they
should be doing because this is just a
wish list
of everything bibi netanyahu has ever
wanted
and i think there's very few people
anywhere that truly believe that
netanyahu's objective has been peace
and if the united states then is
aligning itself with whatever netanyahu
wants and it's not wanting peace
well that creates a major problem for
the united states and the region
it's already been bad enough as it is
but it's going to get even worse going
forward i suspect
well could this be a trap that
that pompeo or the trump administration
is is
laying for democrats that are about to
take power
because they can say then if you're
boycotting
israel then you're an anti-semite and
that's going to play well
with evangelical christians for example
in the united states
absolutely i mean part of the plan here
is very much to try to
make sure that republicans are seen
as the pro-israel party in the united
states
netanyahu has long given up on the idea
that his closest allies in the united
states would be the american jewish
community
the american jewish community
overwhelmingly votes for democrats they
are
overwhelmingly opposed to donald trump
they're overwhelmingly
in support of the iran nuclear deal and
they're very very
skeptical if not opposed to settlements
so those are not his allies his allies
are evangelical christians who actually
have a theological
affinity with israel one that is
somewhat strange at the end of the day
because they envision
that israel needs to get strong in order
for christ to return but at that moment
anyone who's not a christian or is not
converting to christianity will be
killed
but that is actually a very strong
motivating factor for people like pompeo
who is evangelical and who's been
talking about these things
quite a lot at least prior to becoming
secretary of state
so let me just ask you one more time
what do you think then we
saw happening today was this early
campaigning by
pompeo for president in 2024 or was he
doing campaign work for trump's fight to
return to the white house in 2024
i suspect this has more to do with
himself than with trump um i think this
has very much to do with the fact that
he wants to be the contender
for the republican nomination in 2024
he has always had an eye on it and
his main competitors are going to be
people like nikki haley and others who
also have a tendency of
aligning themselves with netanyahu so i
think this is an effort by him to give
himself a leg up vis-a-vis that
competition
the devastation for u.s national
security and the region as a whole
is not even a second concern i don't
think it's a concern at all
unfortunately
triniparsi executive vice president of
the quincy institute for responsible
statecraft
for it is always good talking with you
we appreciate your insights thank you
thank you so much
appreciate it well this week the
palestinian authority
said it will resume its security
cooperation with israel
that cooperation ended six months ago in
protest against israel's plans to annex
large parts of the west bank
palestinians say settlements would
undermine any possibility of
establishing
a palestinian state israel claims
historical and religious rights to the
west bank as the ancestral
land of the jewish people some say the
palestinian decision to resume security
cooperation with israel
is in part a response to joe biden's
election
victory in the u.s
all right let me pull in now akron baker
he is a palestinian analyst based here
in berlin he is a former communications
advisor
to the palestinian minister for
jerusalem affairs
alchemist good to see you again um
pompeo met with no palestinians
today and he said israel has shown how
israeli settlements can be done legally
your take hi
nice to speak with you again look pompeo
is not acting like a secretary of state
pompeo is acting like a pompous jackass
who's pandering to the extreme right
wing of the republican party
um he's breaking every norm rule
every regulation of international law
and meeting with
and going to an israeli settlement this
man is only to be
taken seriously is that he's dangerous
but his thoughts
are so fringe are so
off the cuff and wrong that no one in
the mainstream will accept it
well let me ask you about what the
palestinians are are thinking
the decision to revive cooperation with
his
israelis is that because they have high
hopes
in president joe biden's middle east
policies and his israel policy
look i mean we have we have to look at
this from two things first of all the
the palestinian authority in mahmoud
abbas is
a spent force uh it
does not have any real legitimacy
anymore not among the palestinian people
the only power it has is
to somehow pay salaries to to to the
people
the fact is that joe biden was elected
president of the united states for great
reason for
deal by the progressive wing of the
party and i'd like to give a shout out
to stacey abrams
what she did in georgia and the
interesting thing is that for the first
time these progressives are not afraid
to work for us national interests and
that means challenging
the israel the right to israel to occupy
palestine
and they have proven that this is not
only elect not electoral suicide
that they have won by being able to say
we are no longer supporting the israeli
occupation weakness and forth and they
continue to get elected
unfortunately the palestinian authority
is as i said a spent force
however the plo or some joint thing
among the palestinian people
is not and that's why i think it needs
to move towards i completely against the
security cooperation
i find it useless well tell me um who
is joe biden then who who should he talk
to when he wants to talk
with the palestinians look
first of all i mean what joe biden can
do there's quite a few things that joe
biden
could make very easy very great changes
which he can do
which will strive towards shall we say
um
to correcting all of the wrongs
committed by uh the trump administration
100 days of his administration well of
course he's going to call mahmoud abbas
because he's there
but this doesn't mean that this is going
to happen i'm talking about the first
hundred days
of course you should call mahmoud but he
needs to immediately
if he can re-ignite
the funding to ottawa unftp uh
unfpa to support multilateralism for the
united states to come back into that
to reopen the plo embassy see it's not a
palestinian authority embassy it's the
plo
embassy in washington um to ask call for
the immediate halt of settlements to
re-state that these are illegal
under international law to declare that
that it's illegal
these are simple things these are simple
wins that he could take
which fit into u.s national security
interests
and long-standing us foreign policy
well we will see in about two months if
that is indeed
undertaken akron baker joining us
tonight here
in berlin arkham it's good talking with
we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
nice talking to you too brent thank you